[Music]
hello babies it's the seventeenth
episode of congratulations how did we do
it
that means we've been growing 17 weeks
strong without a [ __ ] hiccup isn't
that amazing I think it's amazing I mean
it's not amazing you know it's not
amazing considering that they can do
brain surgery and take out cancer in
your you know a mouth and [ __ ] but it's
amazing in the sense that it's that
white girl amazing [ __ ] when they're
like oh my god it's so amazing and
they're just talking about like sushi
it's amazing in that sense uh so thank
you for helping out and being on this
journey with me hate when people say
things are a journey when you're not
actually trekking through the jungle but
we're going to call this a journey the
17th 17 week journey that we went
through together mostly me and you guys
were there to kind of just over seeing
it like how um like in The Hunger Games
when the people who created the Hunger
Games were just kind of like watching
everybody killed themselves even though
it had nothing to do even though they
didn't really have anything to do with
it you guys are those [ __ ] people
you guys are those uh the bad you guys
are the bad guys basically and I'm the
hero and that's how it's going to be but
you know what nonetheless you guys are
my babies and hi um I'm hearin I'm here
in Toronto and I'm here I'm back in
Toronto because we had to finish the
movie that I'm doing called life in a
year and I'm here for another week and
this time around in Toronto not so
lonely a lot more fun the weather's
awesome
I have a buddy that I've been hanging
out with and he's been taking me around
showing me some stuff also there are
other cast members here now that I've
been hanging out with um and so this
Toronto looks like a little bit more of
a place that I might move to which I
won't but you know what I mean you look
that you feel that way sometimes when
you stay somewhere and for a while
you're there for a while I mean I've
been here for four weeks total now it's
going to be another week and you get
that thing we're at the end of the movie
where you're like alright it's time to
leave and then somebody's like I'm
staying and they're like what they're
like
I'm staying man you know there's nothing
for me out there I belong here you know
Brent Morin and I used to do that joke
when we were on the road together when
we were on the undateable tour or when I
think way back when when he used to open
for me we used to be like we used to
like pretend we were leaving we were
when we were leaving
unlike the Sunday from the road and he'd
be like we're staying it was funny miss
those days but you know I miss these
days sooner or later that's that's the
thing about retrospect retros retro
stacked or retrospect retrospect because
it candy coats everything retrospect
doesn't it right you could be you can
spend one month getting you're getting a
[ __ ] hot poker in the ass uh and it
would suck and then in five years you'd
be like God remember that remember that
how it sucked didn't it but [ __ ] man as
some about it he's [ __ ] getting
through it all I mean yet hurt my
[ __ ] but just I don't know man so
funny right retrospect does can decode
everything like that I've always thought
that too ever since I was cuz with a
[ __ ] liked high school I hated high
school hated it hate it hate it at like
in the hold in living color [ __ ] and uh
and then I I [ __ ]
went back to the high school like a year
later just to walk around and I was like
guy this still sucks but then I went
back like six years later and I was like
ah man it's pretty cool then you know
super creepy that I was six years later
in hanging out of a high school but
anyway let's not talk about that so yeah
this is episode 17 and I've been having
a great time in Toronto
I've had some days off I'm like the I
don't know like the fifth I'm like the
fourth or fifth main character in this
movie so I don't shoot every day so I've
been I've had a lot of downtime so I I
have been buying clothes and shoes and
coffees and yeah you know that's the
thing about not having a nine-to-five is
like you spend a lot more money if you
don't have a nine-to-five because you're
not you know your work you're not
spending money you're making money but
when you have days off and you're in a
[ __ ] great city you spending money
especially if you're making money you
spending it um so I've been doing that
and it shouldn't be but whatever [ __ ]
you know uh what is it about this is how
I want to I want to ask this question
pose it to you [ __ ] babies what the
[ __ ] you think it is about how come a
flight attendant guy flight attendants
why are they all gay right I mean have
you ever seen a straight guy flight
attendant what is that
that's so weird you wouldn't think it
would be a job that get a gay guy would
gravitate towards like why is that what
is it about being 30,000 feet in the air
what is it about being a high up that
makes you want to [ __ ] guys you know
what I'm saying like granted there's no
way they get up there and then they're
like wait a minute
hmm one of [ __ ] guys it's they're gay
and then that's just something but
basically is to a steward or a
stewardess right is just a waiter
on a [ __ ] airplane kinda and we all
guy waiters aren't gay but also all
flight attendant gay guys are gay I mean
what 90% I don't know I mean they're not
all gay I'm obviously generalizing it's
a comedy podcasts don't crucify me um
but what the [ __ ] is that um they're up
in the air they're just you know what um
[ __ ] these checks I'm gonna hey Ted you
uh you feeling like a like Ted's another
straight flight attendant that a
beginner hey Ted you um yeah you know
what never mind
and then Ted's like no no what say it is
like nine ever mind uh it's kind of
weird uh like look it you see that girl
down there and uh I think she's in row
15 she's like it's 15 B and Ted's like
yeah yeah yeah the blond girl the the
big boobs and the thin waist right and
you said yeah you see that girl yeah all
right you know what never mind never
mind and it doesn't no no no no say it
say it III I want to see where you're
going with this because they're both
like feeling like they understand each
other he's like nah right well okay look
this is weird this is very weird because
but I'm just gonna say it cos [ __ ] it
right when she boarded the plane
I thought god damn like she is just I
want to I want to have sex with that
girl right and then and then he says but
now that I'm looking at her and we're 30
now that I'm looking at her and we're
just saying and Ted says at the same
time as the other guy says yeah yeah
yeah you you don't want to [ __ ] her
anymore right and they're like yeah
you'd rather go shopping with her yeah
let's yeah and then that's just how I
feel like that's how it
just like the higher up you are the more
chance you are to be gay right but then
if you think about it that's how it is
though cuz when you when you're up at
the in the Empire State Building up top
like you get like when you're up there
and you look over you you go you're like
oh my god like that's you know what I
mean you're that little that [ __ ] comes
out of you like oh my god
look at that down there who all the
people you know what I'm saying I think
that there's some some logic to that
like in heaven way up in heaven
everybody is just women or just like
come on guys please it's been so long
and the guys are just like we're too
high literally with dicks in their hands
just not there's other men and they're
even like we would [ __ ] you if we were
you think you know you think about that
and also to the more you think about it
like coal miners guys who go underground
guys who work in like sewers I mean come
on dude no gays down there zero gays
only only men who [ __ ] only women and
not even just attractive women they
don't give a [ __ ] so not gay cuz they're
so underground and they're just like you
know the second they break above ground
they're just like Huma Huma [ __ ] and
that's what hell's like down down way
down underground under the earth right
you see uh you know if you're a woman
don't go to hell you know I mean that's
your hell you're just getting [ __ ]
every day by some [ __ ] troglodyte
right some construction worker that you
don't want to really kind of have inside
you so all I'm saying is
if yours you know Stuart you're probably
going to be gay if you're not gay
already you're gonna be gay so and
that's fine I'm not making fun of that
go far guys all day long but do it
you're gonna do it on you're gonna do it
on a plane so it's all I'm saying it's
all I'm really ever saying honestly No
so I've been uh I had a lot of down time
and I've been doing a lot of TV watching
there's a new show on called cooks vs.
cons and it's on the The Cooking Channel
and I feel like they're running out of
[ __ ] like they did iron chef 47 times
and then they did drying diners
drive-ins and dives and dorks 75 there's
a million that's on all day and then
there's like other ones like Barefoot
Contessa which is like weirdest [ __ ] and
then they used to have Paula Deen but
not anymore because she said the N word
it's crazy though by the way you can
that you can say one word and then
that's it for you like that's actually
amazing that there's one word if you
have a job you have a job and then if
you say one word and I granted I know
it's an awful racist word but there's a
word you can say where you don't have
the job anymore
isn't that amazing isn't that [ __ ]
amazing that you can just say one word
and your life is different it's magic
it's [ __ ] magic actually that's the
magic word it changes your life for the
worse
just don't say it but yeah it's pretty
amazing that there is a word that can
[ __ ] change your life and it's not
presto and it's not abracadabra it's the
N word or it's a lot other words too you
know I mean you if you say you know you
know racial slurs or any kind of bigoted
term you can just get fired as [ __ ] um
but yeah so there's the word there's the
word there's the show crooks and versus
cons and basically they have four chef
quote-unquote chefs and there's a judge
there's always by the way there's always
too many judges on them now I've done
one of these shows I was on beat Bobby
Flay and there's just too many judges I
was one of the judges and then there was
also another judge you need one judge on
these shows but and also you have yeah
Bobby Flay - just won't there's too many
okay now I know granted I was the
quote-unquote even though I'm not that
famous I was the celebrity judge of that
one [ __ ] show and then there was the
actual food person that was good at it
um uh and so she kind of would let led
me she was a Food Network Star already
and she was kind of telling me what what
was what um but because I didn't know
what the [ __ ] I was saying but there's
there's like three or four judges on
this crooks verse versus cons and then
there's a host who's also kind of a
judge in himself this is too many
it's like [ __ ] twelve Angry Men only
cooks vs. cons version the food 1212
hungry men so so I'm now I'm watching
the show and there's four cooks right
and but two of them are not cooks two of
them are professional cooks and one of
them and I'm sorry and two of them are
cons meaning not convicts
they're not [ __ ] they don't work at
prison in prisons but they have they're
like other things or like a
schoolteacher or like a [ __ ] your
banker that just I guess no either know
how to cook or learn how to cook for the
show I don't know and it's up to the
judges to decide first of all somebody
wins with the best dishes and then but
it's up to them to decide which what do
you call it which a person is the cook
in which persons are the Carla Kong are
the cons and so it's and by the way I
don't know if it's because I'm a
comedian and like I know how to like I
feel like comedians are really good at
reading people because you have to read
audiences and you have to know what
they're into and what they're not into
it is so [ __ ] easy to tell
immediately who the cooks and the cons
are it's not hard at all I feel like
they get hung up on the tasting of it
[ __ ]
by the way cooking shows are so weird
that they're so successful because you
can't [ __ ] taste the [ __ ] food is a
tasting based experience I mean if you
set the aliens hey we're going to put on
a show and they're going to have you
know you're going to we're going to show
how to cook the food and then we're
going to show people eating the food and
then that's the show the aliens would be
like Linton does it pleasure your taste
buds you'd be like no you just watch it
and they'd be like annihilate it planet
Earth it just it just doesn't make sense
uh really but it but about I watch it
all day long when I'm in Toronto and
it's so easy dude it'll be like like it
besides the fact that they look the
people who aren't cooks they shuffle
around like they don't know a kitchen
and then the chefs the actual chefs are
like but I bam bam you got the thing on
bam bam move it bam bam bam they're
sweating too like bam bam bam they got a
lot of [ __ ] on the line but the guy
who's a yoga instructor is just like
calmly moving around like if I lose [ __ ]
it who cares I'm not a cook I have known
no bragging rights I mean granted they
win money and they all want to win the
money but but it's so easy to tell like
at the end like at the during the
tasting thing they're like I saw what
you have here and one of the guys is
like well I made a trout with a bechamel
sauce and mixed with a white wine
infusion and I turned it over it's
upside down so there's a little bit of a
crisp on the bottom which ends up being
the top which is very unorthodox in a
trout dish and I topped it off with some
carrots dipped in curry if you wish it's
off on the sonnet and the curry is a
little bit less spicy than normal curry
because I didn't want it to overpower
the trout I mean like I'm very
interesting okay and then they'll be
like to the second guy and what do you
have here and he'll be like I made one
cookie
like oh yeah okay well that's the con I
made one cookie I have an M&M in that
and they're like mmm and then I like
okay chefs or uh okay judges who's the
cook and who's the con and they're like
you know I really like they just like
[ __ ] think about it too much
they're like I really like the UM the
sauce and I loved how you had the white
wine reduction and the crispy part was
okay but you know what I just don't
think that the carrots um really uh
played nicely with the curry so I'm
gonna go ahead and say you're not an
actual cook because I liked the cookie
uh it had one M&M in it and although I
would like to have Mormon I think the
ratio and mm to cookie was good so I'm
gonna say that you uh what was your name
again my name is Steven okay I think
you're the cook and Stevens like and
they're like well Steven are you a cook
or a con and Stevens like I said it
oh he's the oh he's a con yeah he's
actually is he a giraffe in a human suit
yeah I'm a giraffe I learn how to speak
I shed I made a cookie I'm a cookie me
I'm a cookie made in giraffe I'm a
draffa make a cookie and I shut it and
they're like oh god oh and the other guy
is a five-star Michelin restaurant owner
it's like come on guys just look at the
guy shuffle around in the kitchen I mean
a cookie or another an amen' nomina and
about their Bismol I put a pepto-bismol
in it
I'm I'm really tall dough cuz I'm a
giraffe it's leaking down one of my four
legs
[Laughter]
like don't [ __ ] with the system cooks
versus cons and then they'll make like
cook vs. cons junior too and they'll be
like who's the cook who's gone and
they'll be like oh they're all actually
cons because they're all seven and none
of them are cooks buy so I watched those
shows though because I loved to watch
those shows and I watched another show
on the National Geographic um Channel oh
and this actually kind of pissed me off
I like national net G I don't like them
bill saying that G oh by the way even
though that's what the channels called
National Geographic you say it so you
don't abbreviate I don't like
abbreviations by the way you call your
[ __ ] self
Nath National Geographic that's what you
call yourself call yourself not geo if
that's your [ __ ] thing call yourself
that when people say oh it's sports or
the worst Diamondbacks hey you the
Dynomax or you the d-backs
if you're the d-backs never say
Diamondbacks hate that sesh instead of
session ah jump off a bridge uh so they
had this thing called t-rex autopsy and
every time I saw it when I went to
commercial break I thought it said t-rex
auto [ __ ] and I think that that would
be the best dinosaur ever t-rex auto
[ __ ]
we found a dinosaur from billions and
billions and trillions of years ago that
is the ultimate what do you call it the
ultimate [ __ ] predator in all of
Earth's history it is the t-rex Auto
passe it would [ __ ] anything it could
find it would put it in its [ __ ] and
automatically [ __ ] it the t-rex auto
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] idiot so um anyway
and every time it we go to commercial
break I would see it and I would say out
loud by myself t-rex Oh
we'll see I watch the whole thing and it
was one of those things you know when
you turned when you just kind of
lounging in bed and it and something
comes on and you're like huh this looks
kind of interesting and you're watching
it and then and then uh and then you're
like been watching it for awhile and
you're like how [ __ ] long is this it
was like eight days long so I was
watching it I was watching it
I'm sorry fixing the mic here I was
watching it and it they basically got
this uh tear it wouldn't it's so done
because they were like oh never in
history has anyone ever found a t-rex
body all intact and like no [ __ ] no [ __ ]
no [ __ ] because they were around fifteen
million years ago and all things
decomposed in [ __ ] twenty five
minutes okay
not really but you know I mean when it
comes to Earth's timeline we are in the
millionth million percent um millions of
particles inside us that are inside all
of the universe so um so uh they
basically had the dinosaurs roam the
earth in the millions of percentage of
what is known as the Earth's timeline in
a year I watched cosmos I'm like I don't
know what the [ __ ] they're saying
there's so many time periods in that
[ __ ] they're like in them if dinosaurs
were alive they would be alive in the
millionth percentage in the millionth
month in the millionth time period
December 31st million in the millions of
particles and you're like any like and
you're literally like I'm getting
smarter but you're not you're getting
Dumber um it's so amazing though so so
I'm watching that was a net crack by the
way so then I now I'm watching this auto
[ __ ] thing and by the way if you just
turned it into tuned in now that's the
best part so I'm watching this auto
[ __ ] thing and and I'm watching it and
they so they're like nobody's ever found
a t-rex intact which is obvious they've
only found some fossils which even then
they don't find them altogether they
find him they found like a little bit of
a jawbone and some [ __ ] large bald
dork is in like North Africa in the
middle of nowhere dehydrating his ass
off and he's like I found something and
it's like the size of his [ __ ] dick
and and it's and and he's like [ __ ]
his pants and they all have that they
all have bad teeth it doesn't matter
where they're from they get there and
they have bad teeth and they're like
this is really amazing because we found
something from a Spinosaurus and this is
an actual mandibular is from the
mandibular actual and they show you it
and it's the size of your [ __ ] nail
and so uh Laura I say large bald dork
because dork any dorama dork any dork
that I say dork like if you're so
passionate about whatever the [ __ ] you
do and I'm a dork obviously about
stand-up but large bald because they're
in the [ __ ] North actor in North
Africa in the middle of the desert and
they're wearing all tan why why can't
you wear anything but only tan in in
North Africa has anybody worn like I
feel like I feel like is the thing if
you're white if you're of a lighter hue
you know a beige you you only wear tan
but if you're a black or you know if
you're of a brown hue you wear
straight-up hot pink like that's how I
feel and you know it's obviously not
right but that's how I feel like any
black guy I've seen on TV in Africa he's
wearing hot [ __ ] pink and every any
white guy he's dressed like a Sean
Connery and medicine man so so now uh I
don't know where the [ __ ] I'm going but
but they had this show and they they
they they recreated a t-rex
the-the-the the team recreated this team
this crazy [ __ ] they they made a
t-rex like out of
you know I don't know prosthetics and
makeup and [ __ ] and it's incredible it's
the size that an actual t-rex would be
and of course they took some liberties I
mean maybe you know some of the t-rex is
I mean maybe some of they don't know
everything about the t-rex but they know
like a lot about it like they know about
the bones obviously because of fossils
and they think they know about the skin
and they think that they have feathers
and [ __ ] which I didn't know but you
know the eyes and stuff that I think
they took some liberties and [ __ ] but
you know they were like this is you know
close enough and so they made this t-rex
and it's and then they have these four I
guess they're all scientists in
different areas and they like cut it
open and it's called t-rex auto [ __ ]
and and they cut open these this [ __ ]
t-rex and it's gross as [ __ ] like it's
how it would it looks like how it would
be and uh and I watch this thing but it
was annoying because they were like oh
you know they never found T Rexes we
never found a t-rex and then and then
they would and then they would go right
to they'd say that the beginning of
every commercial break like right when
it would come back come back but then
they would be like so since we found
this t-rex you know I had no idea it was
gonna be like this and then you and I'm
a smart person when it comes to [ __ ]
like that even I would be like wait this
is did they find in her this isn't real
but then obviously I'd be like well
obviously it's not [ __ ] real I would
you hear about that the second it came
out you would have to wait tough luck in
National Geographic would show you but
it came out like 2015 this is a rerun
like this is not how I would learn it
right but it was the acting was so bad
some of the guys were so bad but some of
them were good there was this [ __ ]
either I can't remember now if it was
British and or Australian well he's long
we it was I guess it was British maybe I
don't remember I know it's totally
different accent but he was like killing
it he was like let's pump the eye out
and [ __ ] look at the ocular nerve um
but it would and this is why I'm telling
story so then I go to like google it
obviously to look and the number one
question is where did they find the
t-rex
for the NatGeo show like come on [ __ ]
idiots
you know it's freaking she can be as
stupid as you want to but come on dude
our only six year olds googling [ __ ]
they didn't find a [ __ ] t-rex they
made it but they were they really tried
to sell it they were like what it's
pregnant and you're like it was pregnant
when they died when it died and I'm an
idiot I'm like oh well no no no no
wasn't it they made it they made the
baby and the thing obviously they
constructed all of it you guys you got
to get on this me on DS train all right
I got these me on DS underwear and
they're awesome pride you understand
pride starts on the inside so celebrate
yourself with me on DS okay
that's what you got to do and you got to
do it because me on DS makes the
ultimate feel-good undies and they got
free shipping right to your door
satisfaction guaranteed do I wear me
undies all the time they're amazing
underwear they're designed in LA every
pair of me on DS is made with micro
modal a fabric 3 times softer than
cotton that's free time socks and cotton
now think about how when you put cotton
up to your face and it's nice
put these underwear up to your face game
over you'll wear these underwear in your
face that's how comfortable they are
they're soft stretchy undies come in and
ever-changing array of colors and
patterns which is very cool because
they're unique whatever your style is
they've got something for you I'm
telling you if you're a dad they got
something for you if you're a kid they
got something for you
you t-rex they got something for you
don't they have your size of your t-rex
well maybe for baby t-rex me on these
believes in people feeling good and boot
and being themselves so that's great me
on DS is putting their money where their
underwear is during Pride Month for
every pair of special edition celebrate
undies you buy during pride me undies
will donate $1 to the Los Angeles LGBT
Center and that's awesome man good for
me undies for supporting the LGBT Center
and if you need another reason to try me
on these they're offering 20% off your
first pair and a satisfaction guarantee
that you'll love them or your money back
just visit you are URL me on DS comm /
Congrats head me on is today and pick up
a pair of special edition celebrate
undies you'll not only get a discount on
awesome undies
you'll be donating to an amazing cause
check out my undies com / congrats today
get a stand huh lift you guys do lift
you got do lift lift believes that being
a ride-sharing driver should be fun if
you havin a good time
so are the passengers only lift offers
in-app tipping when your when you drive
for lyft you keep 100% of the tips a
hundred percent you don't to split the
tips drivers have been paid over 150
million in tips since the feature was
introduced
experts are sorry about that Express pay
lets drivers get paid almost instantly
instead of waiting for weeks lyft has
even taken the guesswork out of pickups
the new amp device uses color coding to
help passengers find their drivers you
can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus
tips you want to make more money drive
more it's never been easier to give
yourself a raise you can do it yourself
you want to raise drive more it's a
simple formula happy drivers mean happy
passengers maybe that's why 9 out of
lift rides get a perfect five-star
rating so join the ride-sharing company
that believes in treating its people
better go to lift Calm / Congrats today
and you can get a $500 new driver bonus
that's lift calm / Congrats lift calm /
Congrats limited time only terms apply
go and chi'lan babies we're all chillin
ahh
we're all chillin
so I don't know you know it's Rhonda
there's a lot of beautiful women that
really are um naturally there's a lot of
naturally beautiful women but then also
they got a lot of plastic surgery man
like I I was talking to some guy from
Toronto and he was like yeah well LA I
was at his restaurant he was like yeah
well LA you know there's a lot of
[ __ ] surgery girls and I was like bro
there's a lot of Toronto man he's like
well there are yeah but you do have the
natural looking girls yeah and I was
like yeah you do but man somebody's goes
with the lips bro oh what's up it's so
weird
like being in a time where plastic
surgery is like I mean dude my buddy was
like look at this chick she's from
Toronto and you show me pictures is one
girl and then he was like I found out
what she used to look like and she
looked nothing like that it's crazy you
can do that and you they look hot now
and it's [ __ ] weird because they're
all looking the same right they get that
little perky nose and they get the
bigger lips and they get their [ __ ]
brows done and there's someone get their
cheeks done and they're [ __ ] jaws you
know I don't know but they're all
looking they look the same you can tell
when a girl gets a lot of plastic
surgery done because they look the same
they look like they're from Stephen
King's sleepwalkers and it's weird man I
don't know why they I don't know what
the hell that that addiction is it's
definitely an addiction though and then
you see the little girls that and then
and then the girl that does that is also
friends with other girls that do that
and they all look like [ __ ] snitches
not chillin out like snitches at a
[ __ ] restaurant eating appetizers
it's [ __ ] crazy we're gonna live by
the year and I don't even think it's
that far off by the year 2000 it oh by
baro by the year 2025 everyone's gonna
look [ __ ] the same there's gonna be
chicks and guys are gonna be like I
don't really care who I go out with I
guess as long as they're nice they'll
look the same and I guess well you don't
maybe it'll good be good because maybe
people will [ __ ] then guys will be
less shallow and just be like oh I'll
just [ __ ] like a girlfriend what who
she is and then
but then that will [ __ ] up the whole
Dubai trip thing that'll [ __ ] up
Instagram you not I mean if all girls
look the same then they're gonna have to
get you know I'm talking about the
[ __ ] the hook jobs right the [ __ ]
escort services where girls pretend like
they're not doing it but they're doing
it that's gonna that that that business
is going to be gone because you're just
gonna be so many girls will fly to Dubai
for [ __ ] $20 and a [ __ ] Kendrick
Lamar CD you know um so yeah maybe it's
a good thing dude maybe it's a good
thing you know we'll lose a lot of
characteristics and [ __ ] in in in the
body and face for for humans because
guys will do it too but um yeah it'll be
it'll be a it'll be good because now
we'll have to learn love people for who
they are and fly them to Dubai for not
so much [ __ ] money guys will be you
know have more money what these girls
got to realize that what they're doing
is they're [ __ ] it up for for all the
girls individually they're making it
good but as a whole they're ruining the
marketplace for [ __ ] hook jobs for
that escort life right I don't know I'm
just trying to [ __ ] help I'm really
just trying to help really trying to
[ __ ] out
guys I got a new I got a new I got new
clothing for him five four looking good
doesn't need to cost a fortune
five four Club is revolutionizing the
way men shop understand that it's it's
it's revolutionizing it each month they
send you a curated box of two to three
items that are hand-picked to match the
current season and your style now
they've done it for me
they sent me stuff I it's legit cool I
mean I'm wearing it it's comfortable
it's awesome been walking around Toronto
looking for Tings
with this these shirts and pants on
they've been helping men with fashion
for over 15 years and to ship to over
100,000 men every every month that's
what they do they know what they're
doing so if you don't that's okay and I
do I feel like I do know what I'm doing
but I still let them ship it to me five
for club will help you build your
wardrobe one month at a time and then
it's cool because you have a bunch of
stuff you're never having a bunch of
things that you can wear whatever you
want to because when you look good you
feel good it's a fact all right you get
a hundred and twenty dollars worth of
clothes for just $60 a month you can
pause or cancel anytime there's no
commitment so that's cool if you're a
little bit jumpy or nervous about it and
as five for club member you will also
receive up to 50% of items in their
online shop and access to exclusive
Members Only items free shipping and
sizing changes go to five for club calm
right now and enter promo code Congrats
and they'll give you 50% of your first
month's package plus a free pair of
sunglasses that's 50% off your first
package at five for club spelled five-0
you are Cl you be calm if you don't know
how to spell go school that's the promo
code I'm sorry and then and then the
promo code is Congrats okay
so you go to go to five four club.com
spell it out fi ve fo you are Cl you be
calm promo code Congrats okay uh now
that was three ads and I didn't do any
in the beginning because I had three in
the middle now if any of you are
thinking about oh you know what I didn't
like when he talked about five four
I didn't like when he talked about me
undies I didn't know like when he when
he taught when he talked about all the
other ones because here's why because
I'm selfish and I don't want to have to
listen to ads because I want to just
listen to the show now what I want you
to understand is Doon alright you
literally want free content and you
don't want me to back up the [ __ ]
Brinks truck got make money that's how
it is if you work the nine-to-five
would you want to work it for free would
you want to not get paid that day now
hey do you always want Brinks trucks to
go forward cuz I don't I'm trying to
back up the [ __ ] Brinks truck dude
fill my garage babies or else I'm not
doing it I love what I do
I love stand up would I do this podcast
for free maybe eight times not seventeen
and this is the 17th time my babies so
help me back up the Brinks truck I
should just do one with only ads and
then be like you welcome you welcome
these [ __ ] want some [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] for free you don't get [ __ ]
free babies unless you know you're like
really [ __ ] you're a real hot chick
then you get a lot of free [ __ ] um so
yeah I don't know as for today the rest
of the day I'm chillin I'm having fun
doing the movie I'm doing I'm having
real a lot of fun it's a drama which is
crazy and it's coming out later on this
year I believe oh I did ADR which is a
sound work for those of you they don't
know what ADR is he going so those you
record your lines over
for the movie or a TV show you did for
this movie that I did coming out on
Netflix called little evil and it looks
really [ __ ] funny it's called little
evil it's with Adam Scott and Evangeline
Lilly and then a bunch of other people
learning in I'm one of those people and
it's funny it's like a horror comedy and
it's coming out on Netflix in the next
few months so be on the lookout for that
called little evil you can put it in
your queue and also man on fires coming
out soon in like a month so look at look
up that put that in your queue you can
do that as well
crystally a man on fire and I'm going to
look at some hashtags here it's it's
time for the congratulations spot
hashtag see who came to system lets you
gain the system today do it
congratulations pod let's see you again
the system my babies um all right how'd
you meet your openers how do you meet
your openers this is from Aaron which is
at its Miller time oh seven um okay if
your last name is Miller Aaron then okay
but if your last names not Miller hey it
change it um how did you meet your
opener he was hilarious opening for you
in North Carolina gaming the system
congratulations pot you know I I meet my
openers she's talking about Michael
anoche but uh who is very funny I've met
my I have a few openers that I do
sometimes
and Craig Conan Jason Collings Dean del
Rey I meet them just doing the circuit
in Los Angeles and I if I like the guy
and if I like their work ethic I'll
bring him with me and they they got to
be a good hang you know otherwise I
don't hang out with some [ __ ] with
with people I wouldn't hang out with
because when you're in places like North
Carolina you don't want you know and you
have nothing to do and you don't know
people there you know you can listen to
the coffee shop alone for so long until
you want to [ __ ] make fun of somebody
and that's how I get my opener so thanks
Aaron Jordan is my name at jour 750 not
bad not bad
Chris Thalia are you friends with the
workaholics cast
congratulations pod giving system I
suppose I suppose he's asked
that because I did an episode of
workaholics called the catch predator
where I played child molester Topher the
cha molester and yeah I'm friends with
the guys are great and they're awesome I
like them a lot and they have a new
movie called out called game over man
coming out on Netflix and Adam hosted
the MTV Movie Awards I believe it was
yeah movie awards and he killed it the
guy's [ __ ] so funny they're all
they're actually also funny there and
they're great guys oh here's a good
question
Mario part 10 nope at bf5 I don't know
it I need to know a little bit more
about that name otherwise change it
what's your take on this see so TV
network featuring the work of comedians
I did I think any any company that's
putting out specials are awesome now
granted there are so many special
nowadays like I mean [ __ ] you do open
mic for four minutes and you get a
special but it's good man
the cream still [ __ ] rises to the top
people see the good ones and I think
there are some great ones on seesaw I
know some great comedians that have done
it on a seesaw dan levy big J you know
these [ __ ] guys are funny Brody
Stephens has one that's coming out
I actually think Brody came up to me the
other day I love Brody's one my favorite
comedians to watch me was like hey man I
mentioned you twice on stage on my
special and I was like okay cool that's
awesome he's like he's so paranoid about
everything he was like because we're
friends Brody and I are [ __ ] good
buddies he's like yeah well I mean you
know I just I was saying how he was like
I gave you like a compliment but I'm
worried that people think I'm making
funny I was like you [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] you are making fun of me that's
awesome I love Brody
oh it's paranoid um so anyway um but by
the way when you send me pictures on
congratulations pod hashtag like how am
I supposed to do that like hey what do
you think of this and then a picture of
like a dog I can't [ __ ] what am I
gonna describe it
am I gonna [ __ ] do understand me how
am I supposed to do it let's go to the
latest tweets this person just wrote
kiss me super weird and
the what I call it avatar is benedict
cumberbatch uh with an elongated neck in
Photoshop so no I won't kiss
Benedict Cumberbatch and in over in a
with a long neck hey Katy Perry did you
know everyone was actually people at
sometimes people don't have [ __ ] to talk
about Katy Perry did the [ __ ] thing
on Sarah alive and she sounded great and
everyone was like making fun of her
because she did some silly [ __ ] moves
who gives a [ __ ] it didn't look that
weird to me maybe I'm just maybe I'm the
weird one
but everyone was like oh man look how
about all the memes and [ __ ] um like
when your white friend comes over and
there's black people there and then she
did the moves like whatever she looked
like a white girl doing the moves but
she's a [ __ ] white girl I don't know
maybe she was trying to [ __ ] hip hop
it up and that was a little a little bit
weird but like she's [ __ ] uh Katy
Perry I [ __ ] think she's talented man
I know I make fun of the Met Gala dress
she had on but she got some [ __ ]
pipes on her and she's a great performer
am I wrong about this and yes pop music
but there needs to be pop music she
[ __ ] kills pop music um I thought she
was [ __ ] good my buddy sent it to me
like a little good news it's crazy and I
was like yeah it's good I don't know I
just like I don't know it looks like she
she [ __ ] cares about it and wants to
do it so I like it and she's got some
[ __ ] his eyes man how's that for
[ __ ] hip hop ended up I'll hip hop it
up all day long - I don't give a [ __ ]
I'll hip hop it in your [ __ ] face so
yeah um by the way I just did I'm doing
this podcast I just did to hit the gym
and I came back naked his [ __ ] I know I
said I was naked last time I did the
podcast and now I don't even have
underwear on straight up dick flopping
out just kickin it
I had a robe on took it off that's how
[ __ ] keeping it real I am doing this
podcast and I'm just in a hotel room and
it's a nicest [ __ ] room I'm very
lucky as DJ Khaled would say bless up
and I'm just staring at a coffee maker
that I've never used because I like to
go out and get coffee because I'm all
about the coffee experience
and I'm around so many genes right now
because I bought a bunch of genes and
I've got the 5/4 stuff that they sent me
bless up man
dj khaled another one I look at my genes
and I go like this another one and then
I look at another one and I go another
one and then I put it on and I go
another one
um I'd only have let's see let's look at
a few more gaming the systems and then
we'll be done
I love that you guys are listening to me
my babies and I'm happy right I sounded
so insecure I'm happy right you can't
say right and um oh here's a good one
ACK oh whoa I don't know what the [ __ ]
this person's name is here but it's
at-at Richie de Graaff and their other
thing when you know this the name is
like our asterisk asterisk HD Astros etc
hazard as rich f Asterix asterisk
asterisk asterisk oh my god kids say
that twice he says he says I Krista Leah
did the fact that you never drink ever
make you feel socially awkward at any
events points in your life yes I don't
drink I never have and some people know
that about me because I mentioned it
every now and then and I do that because
it's me and I want people to know that
but um yeah hell yeah man [ __ ] yeah I
felt in my head during parties all the
time I used to until I did stand-up and
then when you bomb in front of [ __ ]
350 people a few times you don't give a
[ __ ] about anything else you literally
have a superpower in in in situations
like parties because you're like oh what
somebody's gonna think I'm not funny who
gives a [ __ ] I've bombed in front of 400
people I love how the number keeps
getting higher and higher as I keep
going I bombed in front of 550 people
use it [ __ ] it doesn't matter to me oh
you're not gonna laugh at me he had a
party really I bombed in front of 4,000
people um no I never bought it for those
of you I would starting to take my life
if I did that holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
horrible would that be there whatever
market um
so yeah it used to make me feel I
remember I was at a party once I was at
a party once uh I broke up with a girl I
was like 22 this was before I did
stand-up I broke up with a girl and my
buddy
my best friend Ryan who I talk about in
my new special coming out here man on
fire June 27th June 27th only on Netflix
he brought me to a party and there was
this girl there I thought she was really
cute and I literally was like how do I
talk to this girl and she was making
jokes and stuff and I was like add I
made a cookie I got a man I met and I
was like I'd literally just like tapped
out I was like I can't do it and that
has never happened ever since I do
stand-up because who gives a [ __ ] what
people think because I bombed in front
of one hundred and fifty cents seven
could drill Ian's aliens um so yeah it
would but yeah so yeah I did definitely
made it awkward like you know that was a
time where I was like oh I went on you
know and I wouldn't like oh I'm on a
drink but Oh drinking would help and I
don't but I would purposely not do it
cuz if I don't drink now then the next
time it'll be easier if I don't drink
now then the next time it'll be easier
to not drink I won't be as awkward just
get through this [ __ ] [ __ ] grow up I
never really was curious about alcohol
though it really cared you know I never
thought my god what's it like to be so
drunk um by the way you know this
insecure Saddam was drunk [ __ ] that I do
the first time I ever did it was with my
brother was so long ago I was like 24
not the first time we ever did about the
first time it became a thing was one
time we were hanging out with a buddy of
ours and he was so drunk and went s
drunk and we did it but again I was a
United spell that s apostrophe dr UNK
and we [ __ ] laugh for a day do it and
now it's definitely evolved a million
times over
so there you have it that's pretty much
what I got going and that's all I got
and my babies you're great so that's it
I think I'm gonna go explore Toronto
Rana I'm gonna go explore Rana I'm gonna
take a shower
cuz I'm sweaty because it took a shower
I mean because I worked out oops said
something wrong
definitely definitely trailing off here
but I got upcoming show dates at
crystally accom go over there and I got
a new I got that new emoji shirt which
is the artwork on my congratulations
podcast [ __ ] you can get at the store
get it from congratulations pod comm or
store crystal calm and it's a cool way
to support my podcast and it's really
good shirt it's like high quality I
don't it's not that [ __ ] shitty stuff
it's made in Los Angeles I you know I
like to keep it real and make it like
nice I don't [ __ ] the cool shirts get
that [ __ ] tweet at me at I'm
sorry a hashtag congratulations pot rate
to review the show guys babies you got
to help me out if you're a [ __ ] true
baby you got it go review the show and
rate it on iTunes Google Play and
stitcher
help a [ __ ] out or you're not
really a true baby you're not in my cult
you're not in the book and baby cult and
man on fire June 27th man I'm fired June
27th that's my special go put it in your
queue right now you got a lot of call
that you got a lot of action to do right
now and if you're a true [ __ ] you
know you treat you true you're not true
anyway Chris Chris D'Elia up here in
Toronto [ __ ] still looking for rude
boys and Tings chillin real hard some
days off but also no date never no days
off you know what I mean how they
hashtag it on Instagram just live in
life and thank you for [ __ ] listening
to my show
17 times those of you have listened to
every episode tweet at me I want to hear
about that
I want to hear if you listen to every
episode I will retweet you
probably okay hit me up babies you guys
are gross
thanks the adulation
[Music]
you